a fired anti-trump FBI agent had his
hands in every single pie Nancy Pelosi
he loses what is left of her addled
brain Plus Roy Moore is back in
Republican good graces we'll talk about
all of it I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show well the news is
breaking fast and furious I was just
joking to all of my producers before the
show that we might have to have a second
show a day because the news is actually
coming too fast to keep up with it in
the last 24 hours we've gotten all sorts
of fallout on the Muller investigation
we'll discuss all of that Nancy Pelosi
says that Armageddon has arrived in the
form of a basically normal Republican
tax bill Roy Moore is again back in
Republican good graces and president
Trump is making some pretty astonishing
moves with regard to Jerusalem so we
will get to all of those things I
promise first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at blinds.com so this
is part of your house they really don't
think about very much right you just go
home you go to sleep you don't think
about the fact that you've got a bunch
of blinds that look like somebody was
beat to death inside the blinds
strangled with the blinds hanging from
your windows it makes your apartment
look terrible it makes your house look
terrible that's why you need to get new
blinds you need new window coverings it
actually makes your house look much
better it upgrades your house look at
your house for just the right price
that's what blinds.com does they make it
really easy for you if you're not sure
what you want or even where to start
with blinds calm you get a free online
design consultation you send them
pictures of your house they send about
custom recommendations from a
professional for what will work with
your color scheme furniture specific
rooms they'll even send you free samples
to make sure that what you're looking at
online looks exactly like what it looks
like in the room itself and this is the
best part if you accidentally mismeasure
or you pick the wrong color if you screw
up blinds.com makes it right even though
it's your fault which is pretty amazing
for a limited time you get 20% off of
everything at blinds comm when you use
promo code Ben again you get 20% off
promo code Ben that's blinds.com promo
clip and 20% off everything that's faux
wood blinds and cellular shades and
roller shades and everything else use
that promo code and rules and
restrictions you apply I'm gonna use the
promo code Bennet blinds comm also so
that they know that we sent you okay so
yesterday there was a lot of fallout
from all of the furor surrounding Mike
Flynn the former national security
adviser who pled guilty to lying to the
FBI and we talked about yesterday
whether this entire thing this entire
Muller investigation is going to turn
out to
nothing with regard to collusion between
the Trump campaign in the Russians but
couldn't snare a bunch of Trump
officials who are too naive to know that
they weren't actually committing a crime
and so lied to the FBI so he could have
a series of situations in which people
like Mike Flynn or Jared Kushner are
caught up in lying to the FBI no
indication Kushner's done that yet but
Flynn already has pled guilty and then
you could have a bunch of talk about did
President Trump encourage them to lie to
the FBI is that obstruction of justice
and if so does that mean that Trump has
to be impeached so we could get a
scandal about a scandal about a non
scandal right no underlying bad Act
people lied to the FBI because they're
dumb or because they're incompetent and
then it turns out that they were told to
lie to the FBI
by people who are also dumb /
incompetent or just didn't know what
they were doing right all of that is a
possibility and a very very significant
possibility and then we find out an
actual bombshell this is late yesterday
evening East Coast time in actual
bombshell drops and that is that there
is an agent and Peter stroke I think
that's pronounced STR Z okay Peter
stroszek
struck stroke okay so I will call him
Peter stroke for purposes of this show
in any case Peter stroke was demoted
this summer why because it turns out
that he'd send anti-trump text to his
mistress why does that matter than a
random FBI agent working with Robert
Muller we're sending anti-trump text
messages to his mistress well it gives
you a window into the mind of this
particular FBI agent well why does that
matter why's this FBI agent very
important let me explain to you who this
FBI agent is this FBI agent was in
charge of the Hillary investigation this
FBI agent specifically changed the
language in former FBI director James
Comey statement about Hillary Clinton
originally they were supposed to say
that she had actually involved herself
in criminal negligence essentially and
this guy was responsible along with
Comey for changing the language to
extremely careless which is a non
criminal standard right you remember we
talked about this at the time that James
Comey had changed the actual legal
standard the legal standard does not
require intent to mistreat classified
information James Comey changed it to
pretend that it required intent and then
he changed the language to avoid the
fact that Hillary Clinton probably
should have been prosecuted well the guy
who actually changed that language was
Peter spruce a kazoo Peter Straub Peter
stroke okay who's that guy that guy
actually changed the language but not
just that
Peter stroke was also the fellow who
interviewed to Hillary Clinton aides
Huma Abedin and Cheryl Mills it turns
out that both Huma
and Cheryl Mills likely wait for it lied
to the FBI where either of them ever
prosecuted no of course not neither of
them were prosecuted so Mike Flynn was
prosecuted for lying to the FBI but
nothing from Cheryl Mills or Huma Abedin
and the guy who's in charge of those
interviews was Peter stroke was sending
anti text message and high Trump text
messages to his mistress but wait
there's more it turns out that Peter
stroke was also the guy who based on the
Russian dossier helped decide to launch
the Russia collusion investigation in
the first place on the FBI level he
signed off on the documents this
anti-trump guy but wait there's more
he's also the FBI agent who interviewed
Mike Flynn so he was the guy in the room
with Mike Flynn positioning himself that
Mike Flynn could lie to him now does
that excuse Mike Flynn for lying no but
it is sort of suspicious like I'm just
wondering do the FBI have one agent like
is the only agent at the FBI now listen
to be fair it's possible he's a top
ranking agent he has his hands in a lot
of pies if he's near James Comey James
Comey 'he's at the top of the food chain
but it is suspicious when career
bureaucrats with actual extreme
political biases are having this major
an impact on presidential races on
transition teams on presidential
workings the whole thing is it does
think a little bit it stinks to say the
least this is leading The Wall Street
Journal to call for Mueller to step down
from his investigation and here's what
the Wall Street Journal says there is no
justification for withholding all of
this from Congress so Congress had
subpoenaed all this information from the
Muller team and the Muller treatment
basically stonewalled the Wall Street
Journal says there's no justification
for withholding all of this from
Congress which is also investigating
Russian influence and has constitutional
oversight authority justice and the FBI
have continued to defy illegal subpoenas
for documents pertaining to both
surveillance warrants and the infamous
steel dossier that was financed by the
Clinton campaign and relied on anonymous
Russian sources well there's no evidence
so far of Trump Russia collusion house
investigators have turned up enough
material to suggest that anti-trump
motives may have driven mr. Comey FBI
investigation remember the steel dossier
was brought to the FBI and then for some
reason the FBI thought it was credible
enough to actually pay Christopher
Steele the spy behind the steel dossier
which had all of these allegations about
Trump some of which have already been
debunked the most wild of which have
already been debunked all of this
reinforces our doubts as the Journal
editorial page about mr. Miller's
ability to conduct a fair and credible
of the FBI's considerable part in the
Russia Trump drama mr. Muller ran the
bureau for 12 years in his fast friends
with mr. Comey whose firing by mr. Trump
triggered his appointment of special
counsel the reluctance to cooperate with
the congressional inquiry compounds
doubts related to this clear conflict of
interest now let's be real here The Wall
Street Journal has been calling for
Muller to step down for at least a
couple of months based on his
relationship to Comey
I still think would be a mistake for
President Trump to fire Muller at this
point especially given the fact that he
now has a an ongoing excuse like a
constant and ongoing excuse to call into
doubt any any any sort of conclusions
reached by the motor team right now he
can say well is on Peter stroke or it
was James Comey and these guys were very
good friends with Robert Muller and
they're all working for the same team
together he's gonna be able to say to
his base no matter what that this is
unfair his base already believes this
isn't unfair the question is whether if
he fires him it looks like obstruction
of justice now as far as whether it is
technical obstruction of justice the
answer is no he's able to fire the
special counsel whenever he wants what
he can't do is tell the special counsel
how to conduct the investigation he
can't tell him I want you to find this
conclusion he also can't destroy
documents to prevent the Special Counsel
from finding them so obstruction of
justice is possible but if you were to
fire Muller that would not be
obstruction of justice if you were to if
he his firing of James coming no matter
what the reason was not obstruction of
justice because that is within his
constitutional purview this was the
point that Alan Dershowitz when my
professors over at Harvard Law School
was making out a lot of he got a lot of
flack for it but here's what Dershowitz
was saying on national TV about the
president's obstructing justice
professor is she right do you see a case
for obstruction building no I don't and
I think if Congress ever - were to
charge him with obstruction of justice
for exercising his constitutional
authority under article 2 we'd have a
constitutional crisis you cannot charge
a president with obstruction of justice
for exercising his constitutional power
of fire Comey and his constitutional
authority to tell the Justice Department
who to investigate who not to
investigate that's what Thomas Jefferson
did that's what Lincoln did that's what
Roosevelt did we have precedents that
clearly established that when George
Bush the first pardoned Caspar
Weinberger in order to end the
investigation that would have led to him
nobody suggests that obstruction of
justice
all of this is right woods what's the
saying
left took this out of context to say
that this means the president can never
obstruct justice in fact Trump's own
lawyer John Dowd who is not a competent
lawyer from what I can see he came out
and said the president can never
obstruct justice that's not true the
president can obstruct justice
obstruction of justice charges were part
of the impeachment proceedings that
would have proceeded against Richard
Nixon they were part of the impeachment
proceedings against Bill Clinton
you can't obstruct justice the way
obstruct justice is by destroying
documents as I said or by instructing a
special counsel that they need to reach
a certain conclusion telling them what
conclusion to reach but what is true is
that nothing Trump has done thus far
actually looks like obstruction of
justice
firing Mike Flynn is not obstruction of
justice firing James Comey is not
obstructing an obstruction of justice if
you fired Muller tomorrow that would not
actually be obstruction of justice and
again all of this is starting to cut in
Trump's favor because the fact is that
people now see the FBI as inherently
biased
you know when Trump first started this
crusade against the FBI I was skeptical
you can go back and listen to the shows
I was highly skeptical I said this looks
a lot like the president covering his
own ass
because he's in some sort of trouble
here and I have no evidence that the FBI
is out to get him particularly because
James Comey may have won him the
election in the last week of the
election with that letter that basically
reopened the Hillary investigation which
in an election that close could have
swung those hundred thousand votes in
the three states the Trump needed in
order to win with all of that said it is
now clear the bureaucrats inside the FBI
and their political biases do make a
difference they do make a difference and
that's why full transparency is
necessary now in Muller's defense I want
to be fair here okay
in Muller's defense Muller did fire
Peters for Zack ado Peter stroke he did
fire him right he did demote him when he
found out about this the problem is he
didn't tell Congress about it so it
looks like he was trying to split the
baby he was trying to minimize the
impact of bias on his investigation but
he also didn't want the public to know
about the level of bias that was
implicit in the FBI's conduct conducting
of the Hillary investigation as well as
the Trump Russia investigation right so
all of that is is somewhat disturbing
but it doesn't say to me the Muller is
so biased that he needs to be fired or
that Muller is is running a bad
investigation at this point it does look
though like he's fishing that's what it
looks like to me it looks like Muller is
fishing and this is all the things he's
bringing now are very far flung from the
original charges remember what Democrats
were saying is that what originally
happened here is the Donald Trump and
the Trump campaign colluded with
so far there is zero evidence of that
actual collusion that has been brought
there's evidence that they wanted to
collude there's no evidence of actual
collusion none okay so that means the
Democrats are not getting what they want
at this point and they're getting
frustrated and so they're looking for
obstruction to to get them out of this
and I'm not sure that's going to happen
okay well in other news Nancy Pelosi is
is going fully insane the Democrats are
going fully insane over this tax bill
this new tax bill is out and we are
going to see a final version of it
they're now going to go to conference
committee the house passed a version the
Senate passed a version there are pretty
significant differences the most
significant differences that the Senate
version has a repeal of the individual
mandate which is a very good thing it
says that you are no longer bound to buy
health insurance it's bad in the sense
that what it's going to do is drive up
insurance premiums in the individual
market because the individual mandate
was meant to force people like me young
healthy people to buy insurance for
ourselves at very high prices in order
to subsidize all the sick people who
also want to buy individual insurance
for themselves I don't buy the prices
rise on the sick people the federal
government is filling in that gap so the
federal government is actually
subsidizing the health care for poor and
and ill people at a higher level than
they were before the removal of the
individual mandate that said it's a very
big move to get rid of the individual
mandate in the Senate bill that does not
exist actually in the House bill that
said we're about to go to conference
committee on it they've picked the
people for the conference committee this
thing is going to pass the house it is
going to pass the Senate there will be a
tax reform bill which is a major
accomplishment for the Trump
administration the Democrats are going
completely nuts over it before I tell
you how Nancy Pelosi has utterly lost
her mind I mean completely and utterly
lost what was left of her already addled
brain first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at MVM tea watches so
MVM tea watches was founded on the
belief that style should not break the
bank all of their styles are minimalist
I own 2m VMT watches I bought one for my
wife as well even though they're an
advertiser I actually spent my own money
to get an MD MT watch for my wife she
loves it that's because they're amazing
looking watches how good-looking are
they because they look like this right
this looks like a $400 watch this is not
a $400 watch all of their watches look
great and as I say they're incredibly
durable last time around I said that my
son bashes the watch about and the watch
is totally fine not only does he bash it
about he loves it too much he stuffed it
in his car seat I couldn't find it for a
week I was heartbroken
we found it there this is the second MV
MT watch he has stolen and stuck in his
car seat so that gives you two pieces of
information
everyone loves em VMC Washington my son
is an incipient criminal all of that
said MV MT watches make a fantastic
Christmas gift a great Konica gift you
can skip the crowds you don't have to
stand in crazy lines of them all and you
get an inexpensive watch that looks like
an expensive watch it is just fantastic
they start and 95 bucks at a department
store four to five hundred bucks they've
cut out the middleman that's how they
can do this over 1 million watches sold
in over 160 countries
MVM t is making gift-giving easy right
now so there MVM t-dot-com / shapiro and
you get any watch plus a free strap all
placed in an elegant gift box ready to
give and shipping is free and if you
don't like it returns are free too but I
promise you once you see it looks even
better in person than it does online
they all have really clean designs MVM
t-dot-com / shapiro
that's MVM t comm / up here when we use
that / up arrow again you buy any watch
and you get a free strap all placed in a
really a nice gift box makes a really
easy gift and relieves you of the duty
of having to actually think about it or
spend tons of money doing it they're
great MVM t-dot-com / appear i'll go
check it out let them know that we say
okay so here is Nancy Pelosi the Botox
as I say has seeped into her prefrontal
cortex and here she is explaining that
we actually have reached Armageddon like
Bruce Willis Ben Affleck Liv Tyler full
Armageddon here we go now it is the end
of the road this healthcare the debate
on health care is life death this is
Armageddon this is a very big deal
because you know why there's really a
very hard way to come back from this
they take us further more deeply into
debt what can you do but raise taxes
they contend that there gift to
corporate America of a trillion and a
half dollars could be up to a trillion a
half dollars will be paid for by the
growth that creates and even their own
people say nonsense not true okay so
Armageddon I love when Democrats talk
about deficit spending okay as though Oh
we'll have to raise taxes like Democrats
care Walter Mondale in 1984 openly
campaigned on raising taxes Barack Obama
wanted to raise taxes Democrat to always
want to raise taxes they love taxes okay
they should be overjoyed the deficit is
being blown out because now they can
make an argument for raising taxes they
never want to cut spending
they love spending spending is their
favorite thing in the entire world
by the way I love when she says it's
time again and then she actually tweeted
out that this was the worst bill in
history I'm not kidding here's what
Nancy Pelosi this crazy loon bet
actually tweeted quote the GOP tax scam
is one of the worst bills to be brought
to the floor in the history of the
United States we will fight with
everything we have to stop this bill
from becoming the law of the land well
good news you don't have much and second
off one of the worst bills to be brought
to the floor in the history of the
United States I would love to hear Nancy
Pelosi's thoughts on the Fugitive Slave
Act of 1850 requiring people in North to
take slaves that had escaped their their
plantations and move them back to the
south I like to hear her thoughts on
public law 503 under FDR that allowed
him to in turn the Japanese one of the
worst bills in the history of the United
States I talked about total lack of
perspective you know it is sort of
fascinating and one of the things that I
find interesting about Nancy Pelosi's
take on this is it's the take of a lot
of Democrats which is that if the
government gives up control over you
this is the end of everything now back
during Obamacare days after the Supreme
Court decision that said that it was
okay for the federal government to force
you to buy things I said this is a
fundamental change in how the government
works it was because it was now the
government telling you that they could
force you to buy things they could force
you to not buy things they could force
you to buy things they had full control
over you that was a major change Nancy
Pelosi thinks that it's a major change
to the country when I get to keep my own
money
if this doesn't provide a stark
difference in how you think the the
country ought to run what your vision
for Liberty is I don't know what does
but suffice it to say that this sort of
nutty polarization is driving some
really really bad politics it's driving
some really terrible politics and it's
this polarization I think that is
leading people to hunker down in the
particular political bunkers and just
stay there and never escape and here's
what I mean so over this is just
devastating in the last day briea
President Trump came out and he endorsed
Roy Moore we talked about that yesterday
came out he said we need Roy Moore in
order to defeat Doug Jones in the Senate
and people on the right and people on
the Left people everywhere have no
capacity none for cognitive dissonance
cognitive dissonance is the term that
means that you want to think one thing
but the facts are the other so how do
you rectify that breach right so the
facts right now are that Roy Moore in
all likelihood credible accusations that
he molested young girls I didn't even
less than a fourteen-year-old girl
molested a 16 year old girl that he had
a habit of hanging out at the food court
and dating younger women I say dating IU
that's that you can't really date a 16
year old when you're 33 which is what
Roy Moore is accused of doing there's
one story where he legitimately called a
girl out of her trigonometry class he
called the high school and said is
whatever her name was Betsy here they
called her out of her class to get on
the phone cuz he's the DA and he said
what are you up to right now and she
said trig okay like the evidence is
pretty solid against Roy Moore here or
at least as solid as it can be without
there actually being a court case so
here's what Republicans could do well
Republicans could do is they could be
honest I would disagree with this
argument but it would be an honest
argument they could say listen I think
Roy Moore probably did it but we have to
stop the Democrats the agenda is just
too important we have to stop them
right as President Trump said during the
last election cycle we have no choice
right you just do that you say we have
no choice we're more the only guy in the
ballot we'll deal with him later he's
only gonna be in the Senate for four
years or two years or however long the
remainder of this term is so whatever
you know you put them in maybe you expel
them from the Senate but we need that
seat to remain Republican what you don't
do is build row more up as some
wonderful Halcyon of morality but that
is what the right has done because we
cannot stand cognitive dissonance we
just cannot okay there was even more
evidence that came out yesterday so here
is some of the the evidence so I want to
show you there's a woman who came out
and she showed that she had a note in
her graduation yearbook he dated her
when she was 17 he was 34 and there's a
note in her yearbook it says Happy
graduation Debbie I wanted to give you
this card myself I know that you'll be a
success in anything you do
signed Roy why is this important it's
only important because the signature is
precisely the same as the signature in
the yearbook for the accuser who said
that he tried to rape her when she was
16 years old and then a bunch of people
online who are saying this is a forgery
- it's all a forgery everything is a
forgery okay if you believe that I have
a bridge in Brooklyn to sell you and you
I have a hard time believing that you
think that Al Franken is guilty or
Harvey Weinstein is guilty or Bill
Clinton is guilty of Juanita Broderick
there's more evidence about Roy Moore
here than there was about Juanita
Broderick and all the right believes
Juanita Broderick and most of the right
does not believe the accusers in the Roy
Moore case that's because people cannot
stand cognitive dissonance now the RNC
has jumped in so this was totally
unnecessary Roy Moore was probably gonna
win anyway even if you wanted him to win
Roy Moore was probably gonna win anyway
so they made the worst move
the RNC withdrew its support last month
right in light of the ongoing
accusations and now Breitbart of course
gets the note from the RNC that the they
now quote stand with the president and
that they are going to openly bat Roy
Moore in this election cycle as they say
the president apparently called up
Arroyo Moore's office and he said go get
him Roy I only hope that he specified
who the um was in that sentence because
otherwise that's super awkward
go get them is not something you want to
say to a prospective child molester in
any case the RNC came out and now they
are saying that they are backing Trump's
decision to endorse more they're not the
only ones Orrin Hatch came out he said
Trump had no choice but to support more
now if you want to make the case again
that you have to support him to stop the
Democrats because of the polarization
because Nancy Pelosi is a kook because
the Democrats have gone so far off the
road that we just have to oppose them no
matter what if that's the case you want
to make them make that case okay I have
the courage of your convictions and just
say yeah the guy's guilty I don't care
the Democrats are just as bad fine well
right just do that do that be honest but
that's not what people are doing people
are finding ways to loop themselves in
pretzels to pretend that Roy Moore is
actually an indicator of how great
evangelical Christians are he should be
he's the new Jesus and the pilots out
there are trying to are trying to
crucify him it's just insane it's just
insane and if anybody says differently
then they're raked over the coals so
Mitt Romney blasts more right Mitt
Romney comes out with this tweet he
tweets ROI more in the US Senate would
be a stain on the GOP and on the nation
I agree I agree because I have a thing
called long-term interests I don't think
it's good for the long-term interests of
the Republican Party to have an accused
credibly accused child molester sitting
in the United States Senate being used
as a club to beat every Republican in
submission you think Trump was a club
used to beat Republicans into submission
in 2016 okay wait till they actually
have a credibly accused child molester
in the United States Senate and you're a
guy who's running for a contested seat
in a contested purple state like
Virginia or Ohio or Florida and suddenly
they ask you do you think Roy Moore
should sit in the Senate no matter how
you answer it's in a campaign ad so
here's what Romney tweeted Lake Hoffman
who is the woman who said that he
attempted to sexually molest her when
she was 14 and other victims are
courageous heroes no vote no majority is
worth losing our honor our integrity now
that last sentence is the one that you
might want to argue with right no vote
no majority is worth losing our honor
integrity as I say before I had a long
conversation with my friend David
Limbaugh the other day he takes the
opposite side of this argument from me
on Roy Moore and what he says is that's
not true right there are majorities
there are votes that we have to lose our
honor for right if it requires us to
side with a bad guy in order to prevent
a million abortions from occurring a
year then maybe you side with the bad
guy now I don't think that's the case
with Roy Moore
I don't think Roy Moore like I still
have not heard the credible case that
Roy Moore is going to be the vote that
eliminates roe v wade I really have not
heard the case a specific case that Roy
Moore is going to be the deciding vote
on the Supreme Court right they still
have 51 votes in the United States
Senate and it's likely they'll pick up a
couple of more here but if you want to
make that case make that case right
that's the sentence to argue with no
vote no majority is worth losing our
honor our integrity but people are
getting upset about this they're saying
there's no loss of honor or integrity
titovs backing a child molester so Roy
Moore responded in exactly kind I'll
show you Roy Moore's response to this in
just a second but first I want to say
thank you to our advertisers over at
Realty shares so if you are looking to
invest right if you're somebody who
wants to build your portfolio and you
don't really know how but you know that
a lot of people make money in real
estate then Realty shares may be for you
it's not an offering of securities
private investments are highly illiquid
and risky are not suitable for all
investors past performance is not
indicative of future results securities
offered to accredited investors through
North capital private securities member
finra si PC so Realty shares com has
demolished the walls between you and
real estate investing you don't need
millions of dollars or even hundreds of
thousands of dollars or even tens of
thousands of dollars you can invest
fractionally in vetted asset so hundreds
of people invest fractionally you reduce
the cost of an initial investment take
$5,000 and you can vest along with a
bunch of other people in particular
projects that Realty shares has vetted
if you make $200,000 a year you may
qualify you can find out today at realty
shares comm slash Ben it's free to sign
up browse investments you set up takes
just a few minutes and then you can
manage and invest straight from your
phone or computer through their simple
secure online process all takes is five
grands to make investment there are no
hidden fees close to a hundred thousand
investors are using Realty shares with
over sixty million in principle return
to investors right now Realty shares has
a special offer just for our listeners
if you go today to realty shares com
/ban that's re alt y shares comm slash
Ben you get $100 for your first
investment so it's not it's not five
thousand bucks is forty-nine hundred
bucks Realty shares comm slash
use the slash pen to get the hundred
dollar discount and get involved in
investing folks because the fact is that
if you think Social Security's gonna be
there for you
it ain't particularly if you're near my
age now all that money's gone okay
forget about it if you actually want to
be wealthy and independently
independently oriented then you need to
actually invest your cash so go to
Realty shares comm slash men okay so
here's how Roy Moore responded to Mitt
Romney and I do get the feeling there
are a number of Republicans who whenever
you say thing like you are compromising
your morality to support a child
molester they can't stand the cognitive
dissonance they can't say you know what
you're right it is a compromising my
morality but you would also be making a
compromise of your morality to sacrifice
the Senate seat to a guy who supports
abortion he'll birth right and then we
can decide who's compromising the
morality more and what the costs and
benefits are and that's an honest
conversation that's a conversation we
could have when we both acknowledge that
morality is being compromised but people
on the on the judge Roy Moore side
refused to acknowledge this compromise
of morality some more rights back either
Mitt Romney has lost his courage or he
doesn't care about truth anymore
sad day has lost his courage doesn't
care about truth judges were more
changed his story again this morning
again he came out and he now says he
doesn't know any of the accusers
he admitted before he knew some of the
accusers then one of the accusers came
forward and said well by the way here's
a note in my in my graduation book from
Ray Morris's well I don't know her I
guess a forgery and then he says
America's reawakening was led by real
Donald Trump not you mit hashtag defeat
the elite hashtag drain the swamp now I
love this appeal to to Trump right the
appeal to Trump is the idea that you
have to embrace all that is bad about
Donald Trump in order to embrace the
policies of Donald Trump or to embrace
the fact that there are Republicans who
are willing to fight back I've always
said that I like that Trump is willing
to punch back my problem is that
sometimes he punches a baby right that's
always been my problem with Trump
sometimes he punches the bad guys and
sometimes he punches a puppy you just
don't know which it's going to be but
the idea that Mitt Romney stands up and
says let's not vote for a child molester
and Roy Moore goes well you're
irrelevant because Trump if I were Trump
I'd be insulted by this if I were from
by we're really I would be I mean I
don't think Trump would be because I
think Trump likes praise but the idea
that America's reawakening was led by
Trump not you mitt and that that
reawakening means vote for the child
molester even if you make the case that
Trump did something mitt didn't which I
agree okay Trump again punch back mitt
did not I fully agree with that but the
idea that that means vote
the alleged child molester that's dad's
dicey stuff at best
and again the defense's that are being
just trotted out here by the by the more
campaign are shall we say garbage here
is that to put it mildly here's a Roy
Moore spokesperson when she was on CNN
this morning the poppy Harlow this was
her name is Jane Porter this was one of
the worst interviews I have ever seen on
national television and that's saying a
lot I've been here for the last year and
a half
okay this was just Wow okay play it
poppy we need to make it clear that
there's a group of non accusers that
have not accused the judge of any sexual
misconduct or anything illegal but what
we're talking about Lee Kaufman even her
own mother said that her report to the
Washington Post that her life spiraled
out of out of control after this alleged
incident
well actually the court records say
differently okay so she starts doubting
all the accusers
she also said here that they're
basically criminals the accusers are
criminals not the guy accused of
molesting children
the accuser they're criminals the best
part of this was she let off the
interview and poppy Harlow is pregnant
and so she said congratulations on your
pregnancy if Doug Jones had his way he'd
abort your baby she really led off the
interview that way here it is you by the
way congratulations on your your unborn
child that's that's the reason why I
came down as a volunteer to speak for
judgment more because he'll stand for
the rights of babies like yours in the
womb where his opponent will love
support killing them up until the moment
of birth Janet thank you for being with
us and I appreciate that well boom right
out the gate there I mean that's a hell
of a party
oh wait crap so I mean but this is the
argument that's being laid out right
again notice the cognitive dissonance
you like judge Moore's position on life
I also like judge Moore's position on
life
you don't like judge more taking a
sexual position on fourteen-year-old
girls but you can't square those two
things so what you end up doing is you
end up going into whatever this lady's
name is Jane Porter land and you end up
saying crazy things so now I'm watching
this on in LA online in real time and
again you know III see it happen on a
regular basis and it drives me up
it drives me up a freakin wall okay
drives me crazy I'll host other other
shows and what a call in there possible
and the entire board of calls will be
you're getting more wrong more totally
innocent I want to see the evidence that
more like what's your evidence lay it
out and the evidence that she lays out
is that she says that the yearbook was
forged yeah that's because that's the
best plan
never I hate these conspiracy theories I
swear to god I hate these conspiracy
theories so much you know why because I
remember back in the last election cycle
when Corey Lewandowski grabbed Michelle
fields by the arm hard enough to bruise
her and then people suggested that there
was some evil conspiracy hatched by
Michelle fields and me in order to get
President Trump and what we had done is
we had secretly planted Michelle fields
near president Trump so Corey
Lewandowski would grab her arm and
bruise it hard enough so then we could
claim abuse and then we could claim that
Corey Lewandowski should step down from
the campaign we were just that nefarious
we tempted Corey Lewandowski in our evil
jewel ways right this is such nonsense
okay there are eight accusers there are
four accusers who have said that Roy
Morris sexually treated them when they
were underage four they've been every
detail they say has basically been
confirmed and we're sitting around
talking about this like this is a real
thing again you won't have an honest
argument about whether to vote for more
here's the honest argument the cost of
voting for more outweigh the benefits or
the benefits of voting for more outweigh
the cost that's the only honest argument
but to pretend that you're not making
any moral compromise whatsoever and
voting for a credibly accused child
molester and the RNC has to sync dollars
in and pretend like nothing is wrong
here is just gross it's just gross and
it's being driven by the polarized
politics it really is because what you
see from the Democrats is the same thing
are you seeing it in the same way from
the Democrats and what I mean by that is
that when you look at the Democrats
today so John Conyers comes out right
John Conyers came out today and he
finally said that he is retiring you
didn't say stepping down didn't say he's
quitting he said he's retiring and not
only is he retiring because we live in a
feudal fiefdom he's handing over his
seat to his son no I'm not kidding he
said he endorses his son so he's a
parent there's an accusation that he
sexually groped a woman in church these
are the people who run our country folks
these are the people and he says to his
constituents by the way you should vote
for my son okay it's not a punishment so
the Democrats are leaving Conyers to
basically appoint his successor in the
royal fiefdom of Detroit and Al Franken
is going to remain and Keith Ellison who
is almost the head of the DNC and who
was a fan of Louis Farrakhan and is an
anti-semite
right this guy is out there on democracy
now of all places defending both Conyers
and Frank and saying they should
evaluate themselves and then you wonder
why people are rallying to Roy Moore
because no one can stand the cognitive
dissonance on the left Franken and
Conyers
fine because they're on the left and on
the right Roy Morenstein he's on the
right and those other people are just so
bad this is how morality dies yours
keith Ellison here's the thing I would
ask every member of Congress including
those to look inside their conscious and
ask themselves just a few questions can
you be effective if you stood up your
whole life to to stand up for the rights
of people and both of them have is it
not a moment now where you apply some
standards to yourself that you will ask
you to be a nice guy right yeah this
worked well from McConnell who said that
he wanted more to step down and then
turn around and said he'll back more
yeah okay so we'll put all of that nasty
news aside and the fact that no one has
any moral scruples and everybody's
garbage well put all of that aside for a
moment and let's talk about some good
news so the Trump administration is
doing a couple of things that are really
really quite good so the first thing
that they are doing that is quite good
is that President Trump announced
yesterday that he was going to change
policy on public lands so first I want
to show you a map of what public lands
look like in the United States okay this
is a map that the red marks areas that
have been marked off by the federal
government and are in control of the
federal government what you'll see is
that in the east there the public lands
are relatively limited and then you move
out west and what you see is the entire
state of Nevada is public land right the
entire state of Nevada the entire state
of Utah is public land half of New
Mexico is public land half of California
is public land half of Oregon is public
land basically the federal government
controls huge swaths of land this was
never meant to be for public monuments
the whole point of a public monument is
that you were supposed to be able to go
see it now that they were gonna fence it
off and leave it right and so they
fenced off the entire state of Nevada so
President Trump came out yesterday about
I think he's talking about the beers
beers ears bears bears bears bears ears
Memorial in Utah and he said that they
are going to restrict the amount of land
the federal government is gobbling up
which is exactly right okay what Trump
says here is exactly right and in his
good policy I will sign two presidential
proclamations these actions will modify
the national monuments designations
of both bears ears
and grand staircase-escalante as many of
you know past administrations have
severely abused the purpose spirit and
intent of a century-old law known as the
antiquities Act okay so what Trump is
doing here is totally necessary now the
left will say oh he's opening all this
up to exploration and drilling and
mining again look at that map again and
what you will see is the federal
government does that if you think they
need that much land in order to prevent
mining then you are out of your mind
okay the federal government under
President Obama particularly did all of
these land grabs it's one of the reasons
why you had all of these these conflicts
with local ranchers and farmers who want
to graze their cattle and there's some
tortoise that the federal government
wants to protect by restricting the
entire state there's a lot of the
conflicts of the Bundy family in Nevada
for example the fact is that all of this
land a huge portion of this land should
be privatized it should not be left in
public hands this was not the purpose of
the federal government protecting
antiquities okay so that's a good piece
of news number one the piece of news
number two is a really huge piece of
news and that is it appears that the
Trump administration is going to move
the embassy in Israel to Jerusalem which
is great okay this is obvious Jerusalem
has been and will be the eternal capital
of the Jewish people and the State of
Israel and the idea that it was not that
it was Tel Aviv which is a secular city
that was founded in like the 1920s the
idea that that is the capital of Israel
is asinine and has never been the the
capital of Israel Jerusalem has always
been the capital of Israel Trump is
doing the right thing now you have the
terrorist regimes that the Palestinian
terrorist regimes who have been voted
for literally the only people that
Palestinians have ever voted for all
terrorists I mean there haven't been
that many votes but every group they've
ever voted for is a terrorist group
Islamic Jihad the Palestinian Authority
Fatah which is the military wing of the
Palestinian Authority Hamas which runs
the Gaza Strip they're now saying oh
well if you do that we'll commit
terrorist attacks yeah what else is new
today ending and why of course you're
gonna commit terrorist attacks this is
what you do if the United States does
not want those terrorist attacks to
occur they should do two things one they
should move the embassy to Jerusalem and
they should say listen this is now the
starting basis for negotiations it's up
to Israel how they wanted to go she ate
with this but this is their capital so
stop with these fantasies that we're
going to push Israel to hand over its
capital not going to happen once that
fancy yacht is off the table
a lot of the terrorism
simply goes away really because all of
the terrorism is driven by hope not by
fear Palestinians don't bomb things
because they're fearful that they are
going to to lose they bomb things
because they they're hopeful they're
going to win they're hopeful they're
going to pressure the United States into
doing things the next step is for
Congress if terrorist attacks occur to
pass the Taylor force act and withdraw
funding from the Palestinian Authority
we give them someone from 300-400
million American taxpayer dollars every
year a huge swath of that goes to either
terrorism or the pockets of the evil
murderous dictators who run that place
or the evil murderous elected officials
in the case of Kamau's we should just
cut off the funding there's no reason
your taxpayer dollars or mine should go
to terrorist entities the Palestinian
Authority is a terrorist entity this is
a great move from Trump if this
materializes I'm sure we'll talk about
this a lot more tomorrow because I want
to lay out the full history of Jerusalem
tomorrow in a little bit more fulsome
way so that you understand that all of
the claims to the contrary about
Jerusalem are just nonsense
serious changes are taking place across
the Middle East like real serious
changes in part unintended consequences
of bad Obama policy the Saudis are now
working openly with the Israelis they're
talking about how they might stop
supporting the Palestinians major
changes taking place and the Trump
administration taking a leadership role
in that so that is actually good stuff
okay so now I want to move over to
things I like and things I hate so we
have time for that but first you're
gonna have to subscribe for $9.99 a
month you can get a subscription to The
Daily wire yes you I'm talking about you
my friend you can have a subscription to
The Daily wire for $9.99 a month that
means you get the rest of this show live
on video it get means that you get the
rest of the Michael Mol's show live on
video it means you get the rest of the
Andrew Klavan show live on video it
means that we have something called the
conversation our fourth episode of the
conversation is coming up Tuesday
December 12th 5:00 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m.
Pacific featuring your favorite me
subscribe today to be a part of the
conversation and ask me questions which
I will alternatively mock or answer and
I'll answer you even if I mock you maybe
but I'll answer those questions only if
you are subscriber the conversation
stream is live on Daily wire Facebook
page daily wire YouTube channel it's
free for everyone to watch but again
only subscribers can ask the question so
to do that you just log in to our
website at daily wire.com you head over
to the conversation page to watch the
live stream after that you type in to
the daily wired chat box and I answer
questions as they come in for an entire
hour so ask the questions that have been
burning a hole in your pocket
subscribe to get your questions answered
by me December 12 5:00 p.m. Eastern 2
p.m.
join the conversation if you want all of
those glories plus this the very
greatest in all beverage vessels he left
his tears hot or cold tumbler all you
have to do is go over to Daly wire now
coming in the annual subscription $99 a
year so it's less expensive than your
monthly subscription plus you got all
the affirmation wonders if you just
wanna listen later go to iTunes
SoundCloud YouTube subscribe leave us a
review we always appreciate it largest
fastest growing conservative post cast
in the nation are we
[Music]
all righty time for some things I like
and some things that I despise so we
shall begin with things I like so
there's a book by Ursula Le Guin that I
read recently called the lathe of heaven
I don't think I recommended this on the
show did I so this is it's quite good
it's it's a science fiction novel which
is an Ursula Guin yeah she's she's a
science fiction writer it does lean left
in some in some important ways but the
the book itself is is very readable I
don't like a lot of science fiction that
is that is heavy on the jargon and this
book really is not it's it's sort of the
basic concept of the of the book is that
there is a main character whose dreams
are impacting reality every time he
dreams the reality shapes around him I
mean like the entire world shapes around
him and then he has a psychiatrist and
the psychiatrist starts realizing that
if he can control this guy's dreams then
he can shape the reality to Mel to what
the psychiatrist want so it's all about
minds and impact on the world and it's a
lot of it is really good and really
interesting the lathe of heaven by
ursula Gwenn worth checking out okay
other things I like so I actually have
to give props to Joy Behar today yes Joy
Behar one of the people who might
despise most in the world Joy Behar over
on the view she so yesterday i mocked
her because she went totally wild she
basically did the Oprah giving away cars
routine but with regard to the Mike
Flynn announcement by Brian Ross that
was false that Mike Flynn had said that
the Trump campaign colluded with Russia
or the Trump told him to go over to the
Russians for help with the campaign that
turned out to be a complete lie by Brian
Ross well joy behar made a huge deal out
of it on Friday's show well yesterday
she apologized you have to give props to
people when they apologize if you do
something wrong and you apologize that
is better than if you do something wrong
and you do not apologize so here is the
execrable Joy Behar doing the right
thing and actually walking back the
stupidity so on Friday's show apparently
I was guilty of premature evaluation
here's what happened ABC News reporter
Brian Ross released a story claiming
that when Trump was a candidate he told
Michael Flynn to contact the Russians
Ross later corrected himself saying it
was actually when Trump was
president-elect now Brian has been
suspended for a month okay so I may have
to take that back anytime you hear Joy
Behar make a sexual joke then you
immediately have to take back whatever
praise you're gonna aim at joy behar
because that's just horrifying but at
least she at least she is correcting the
record so good for joy behar for doing
that I have to admit there's part of me
that hopes that because I have now given
just the the merest of de minimis
niceties to Joy Behar that now I'm
invited on the show this is one of my
lifelong dreams is to appear on the view
I will admit it this is one of my
there's one of the things I would love
best in life because it would be epic
television let's be real folks if I were
on the view who would not watch that
maybe no one would watch it but I would
be on the view and it would be so much
fun and the clips would be incredible
yes I would ask Whoopi Goldberg about
rape rape I would ask so many great
questions to all the members of the okay
I'm not gonna make my pitch for being on
the view anymore okay time for some
things that I hate so as I mentioned
yesterday today in the Supreme Court
there was a big hearing over what they
call the masterpiece cake shop case the
masterpiece cake shop case is basically
a gay couple went into the the cake shop
of a religious Christian the religious
Christian said sure I'll give you a cake
for your gay wedding but I'm not gonna
put a cake topper with two dudes on top
that Norma gonna put any messaging about
congratulations to Bob and Steve drew on
their wedding because that's not in line
with my religious feelings he also
refuses to do the same thing for divorce
parties he refuses to do the same thing
for four other four anti-gay messages if
you go in there and you want to put on
your cake I hate gay people he won't do
that either so this guy has you know his
own standards for where he will exercise
his free speech rights and how he will
use his business skills and the gay
couple decided that they were going to
target this guy because this was taking
place in Colorado okay the idea that
there are no bakeries in Colorado that
will cater to gay people is fully crazy
okay of course first of all it's hard to
find a cake shop across the United
States that is not staffed by gay people
you found the only cake shop in the
United States that is it that is staffed
by a religious Christian and then they
set this up
this happens on a regular basis and
sometimes it's good and sometimes it's
bad but it's never the narrative the
medium wants to tell so in the case of
Rosa Parks which is a good case right
Rosa Parks had plans in advance to not
sit at the back of the bus so that there
could be a civil rights movement behind
her and something she coordinated with
the NWC and n-double-a-cp in advance
that's a good thing this was also
coordinated in advance here is the gay
couple the vindictive vitriolic nasty
gay couple who decided that it was
absolutely necessary to force this
Christian Baker to violate his own
religious beliefs so they could have a
cake topper that made them feel better
about themselves
I mean as opposed to you know being on
national television of holding hands cuz
you're gay
I mean clearly these people don't get
enough attention and respect what they
really need is a random religious Baker
to bake them a cake
no no hell I mean it's just gross here
they are at MSNBC talking about what
wonderful kindly gentleman they are even
as they destroy this guy's business got
lost 40% of his business the state tried
to force him to retrain family members
in sensitivity all because he just wants
to exercise his business as a religious
person exercises his business just
absurd anyway here here are these
jackasses on national TV when a business
decides to open its doors to the public
they need to serve the public equally
and you know this whole time that's what
we've been asking for is just to be
treated equally and in the public and
the reason why we're here today is
because we've heard so many stories of
discrimination nationwide over the past
five years and you know we're standing
up for ourselves in this but we're also
standing up for all these other people
okay so first of all at the time they
did this at the time that they did this
Colorado did not recognize same-sex
marriages you understand what they're
saying here well they're saying here is
that the state of Colorado at the time
that they did this did not recognize
same-sex marriage but the Baker is
supposed to recognize their same-sex
marriage by law he's supposed to only
recognize it but celebrate it by law at
a title in the state of Colorado did not
even recognize his same-sex marriage do
you understand how insipid and insane
this is okay first I don't know what
these guys do for a living I don't know
what they do for a living but let's
assume for a second that that these
douchebags
Charlie Craig and David melons let's
assume that they are speech writers for
a Democrat okay let's assume that I
don't know if that's true or not they
probably aren't but let's assume that
they are for a second could I walk into
their office today and say
listen you guys you're great speech
writers this is your skillset you are
just amazing at this I want you to write
me a speech talking about how homosexual
activity is a sin under Leviticus can
you write that for me are they allowed
to say no are they not allowed to say no
so according to their own lights they
would not allow me say no right because
they because they would then be
rejecting services to me even though
their services they don't want to
provide it doesn't matter I want them to
provide the services they'll give their
services to anyone else
but they won't give their services to me
as a violation of my rights as a
consumer see the thing is that everyone
who looks at this case knows this isn't
about consumer rights this is about
violation of free speech this is about
violation of freedom of association this
is about them wanting to force someone
to green-light their lifestyle that is
what they are looking for and maybe you
think their lifestyle should be
Greenland that's your problem
but it's not the religious Baker's
problem and guess what they don't have
to green-light his lifestyle either okay
they don't have to there he's not
looking the Baker in this case Jack
Phillips he's not looking for them to
green-light his lifestyle he just wants
to be left alone
my my sympathy and the moral impetus
always lies with the person who wants to
be left alone okay in the United States
when it comes to government action the
moral impetus always lies with the
person who wants to be left alone so
long as they are not harming anyone else
or removing their rights these people do
not have a right to the services of a
religious Baker they're never the right
to anyone services you do not have the
right to my services I don't have the
right to your services if we don't
respect the fact that we cannot demand
crap from each other just because we
want it and what is it what are we three
and my son can demand things for me he's
one and a half years old my daughter can
demand things for me she's three and a
half years old she's my kid and she's a
child but adults don't get to demand
things of one another they don't have a
right to and these people do not have a
right to the artistic skill of a
religious Baker they do not okay time
for a brief deconstructing the culture
so I'm not sure that we actually grabbed
the trailer for this but there's a new
movie coming out called the post this is
this movie it looks absolutely
insufferable that is with Meryl Streep
and Tom Hanks so it's got the greatest
of the great actors by the way I'm
unpopular in my opinion here just like
most of my opinions but Meryl Streep and
Tom Hanks
I believe are both wildly overrated as
as actors
I think Meryl Streep is McCann
the famous quote I think from I think
it's from Katherine Hepburn about Meryl
Streep is the problem Meryl Streep is
you can always see the gears turning and
that's right it's a she's she's
technically perfect but you never feel
it I say oh that's how humans should cry
but is there like oh my god I feel so
bad for that person that person's crying
it's always like ah that's pretty good
crying right there by Meryl Streep boom
and Tom Hanks has not been good since
big sorry to break it to you Tom Hanks
is a better comic actor than he is a
dramatic actor Tom Hanks in castaway is
one of the best comic performances of
all time if you ever want to have fun do
comic bits on castaway which is a
hilarious movie I don't know why
everybody sees that as like a dramatic
sad movie I think it's really funny I
mean it's a guy living alone on an
island talking to volleyball it's really
freakin funny so that's it so in any
case this this movie is is really it's
gonna be insufferable it's basically
about how the Washington Post The
Washington Post is just the most heroic
people now you know we already had this
movie about about the Boston Globe with
regard to taking on the Catholic Church
of sexual abuse I liked spotlight I
recommended it on the show I thought was
a good movie but this idea that the
Washington Post they were in danger that
watch it they were going to be jailed
the founder of the Washington Post was
going to be jailed here's the
description a cover-up that span for us
precedents push the country's first
female newspaper publisher and a
hard-driving editor to join an
unprecedented battle between journalist
and government okay do we need any more
self congratulatory tones from Hollywood
so we need them like the journalists
celebrate Hollywood Hollywood celebrates
the journalist I haven't seen the movie
yet so I'm not gonna critique the
historical veracity of it all I will say
is that there are two types of bias in
Hollywood in the media one is bias with
regard to the material the date that
they portray right actual lies they tell
on screen and the second is selection
bias and the second is the selection
bias what do they choose to cover where
do they choose to put Tom Hanks and
Meryl Streep do they choose to do a
movie about Whittaker Chambers no they
would never do a movie about Whittaker
Chambers right that's it one of the
great stories by the way in American
history the new movie has never been
made about an American newspaper editor
right Time magazine editor Whittaker
Chambers testifies that a member of the
US government a high-ranking member of
the US government it's u.s. Department
of State helping who is partially
responsible for the garbage Yalta
agreement between Franklin Delano
Roosevelt and Stalin and Churchill that
that that that guy Alger Hiss was
actually a Soviet spy and it turns out
not only was he a Soviet spy but
Whittaker Chambers actually got
microfilm that was
supposed to be passed to Alger Hiss he
had to hide it in a pumpkin patch like
that's an amazing story has that ever
been on film though but we get yet
another story about how to mock reseed
eyes in darkness and yada yada and the
media are so great so the selection
biases your attaining this is one of
these movies that is that is definitely
aimed at Oscar bait I hate Oscar bait so
some of the other movies that are Oscar
bait this year there's the army hammer
flick about about homosexuality and some
26 year old guy sleeping with a 17 year
old boy which I guess is wonderful
that's winning the LA Film Choice Award
they always I was going to last room I'm
not sure I did I I did I will do this
here the intersectional Oscars and I'll
predict Oscar outcome by
intersectionality right by which film
and which performance is the most
intersectional pretty pretty accurate
most of the time like you could have
called moonlight last year that one was
a pretty easy call I feel like the post
is going to lose out to something that
is something about victimized black
people or victimized gay people that's
usually the way that it works in
Hollywood unless they're on a rotating
system in which case it might be the
journalist again okay well we will be
back here tomorrow and we'll talk about
whether this big move on Jerusalem
happens or whether it does not and what
that means I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex zingaro audio is mixed by
Mike or Mina hair and makeup is by Jess
well para the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2017